is a crisis of femininity at the moment
do you think that women are struggling
for good Role Models right now I can't
tell you there's a single woman that
I've ever watched growing up and thought
I want to be like her that's not because
there's anything wrong with the women
out there maybe it's my values don't
connect with current environment but
what I would love to see is how we can
Embrace every part of being a woman I
just love being different to a man I
have no desire for complete equality
with a man it just doesn't make me feel
good knowing that I can do everything a
man can do because I'd rather that you
complete the areas of my life where I'm
deficient and I complete areas of your
life where you're deficient